she felt like she was trying to warn the
stars the milky way
don't come here stay away there are
humans here and you can't trust them
she stretched with every motion letting
it all go she should have been scared
but she wasn't she was going to her
death
and that sucked she would have liked to
live longer to see
jim again and alex and amos she would
have liked to tell jim all the things
she'd been so careful for so long not to
say
somewhere out there philip was with his
father the way he had been for years
since he was a baby
and sin poor sin already as dead as she
was going to be because he'd seen her in
the airlock and thought stopping her
would have been saving her
thought the life she had with marco was
worth having she wondered what would
have happened if she'd stayed if the
chet's mocha had flown without her
would jim have set off the bomb she had
to think he would have
he wasn't a man who reigned in his
curiosity well
hey guys pete here this is my season 5
ending explain video for the expanse
i made a full breakdown of everything
that happened in the finale
and now i want to take a closer look at
the ending and what it means
be warned this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't finished season
5.
i'll be referring to the books the tv
series is based on but won't be touching
any future spoilers in this video now
that you know let's get started
to understand the ending of season 5 we
have to take a quick look at what made
it possible
the opening of the ring gates at the end
of season 3 provided humanity with
a new frontier 300 habitable planets
breathable air wide open spaces to be
claimed
resources to be extracted and you get
the idea
it's a gold rush waiting to happen in
season 4
the inner planets led by the un are
trying to prevent a mass
exodus to the planets beyond the rings
for a lot of reasons
but mars is the most important one for
where we're at
mars has humanity's second largest
military but not really much else to go
along
with that now that the ring gates are
open mars is over
their planetary dream relies on a
generations long commitment that is no
longer viable
the question is what's gonna happen to
that military in the last episode of the
fourth season
we learned that the belter marco inaros
has gotten hold of some martian stealth
material
and in the beginning of season five we
see him unleash his plan of hurling
stealth-coded asteroids at humanity's
home planet
on its own this would have been an
unprecedented act of terror but it was
part of a larger coordinated attack the
top scientist from protogen's
protomolecule research was kidnapped the
seat of the moderate faction of the opa
at tyco
station was attacked and their leader
fred johnson was killed
fred was in possession of the last
active proto-molecule sample in the
system
and that was stolen there was an attack
on the martian parliament building
and we also learned that marco has come
into possession of a fleet of martian
built gunships
the leader of the free navy paints
himself as a champion of the belters
an exploited class of humans who can see
their relevance and their place in the
system
fading marco's message is that taking
power through
force is the only option belters have
left and this
is their final chance while his violent
means are far too extreme for the
average belter the injustices
and grievances he speaks to are real
while the expanse has always done a
great job with
battles in space political intrigue and
mysterious alien artifacts
its center of gravity has always been
the crew of the rasanante
pretty regular folks with checkered past
just trying to make their way in the
harsh environment of space separating
the crew changes the formula but it
works for a couple of reasons
first it allows us to learn about the
secret past of amos and naomi which have
been hinted at
heavily throughout the series and how
their past made them who they are
second when things go pear-shaped and
the crew can't get back together it
enforces just how
important their found family connection
is to them
captain james holden is still haunted by
his experiences with the investigator
and the proto-molecule
and he spends most of the season
sidelined as his crew gets split up
marco's attack sending everything into
chaos helps him see what it's like for
the people who care about him
when he rushes off to throw himself into
these crazy situations trying to save
the world
at the beginning of the finale he's in
the rossi with a temporary crew
burning towards the chet's mocha to try
to rescue naomi
he learns that he's being pursued by a
small fleet of belters in a situation
where he can't win if a fight breaks out
running would mean abandoning the rescue
effort because
even though alex and bobby are on the
way there too they're in the razorback
which doesn't have any guns
in a situation where there are no good
options holden decides to sacrifice
himself for his crew
and a plan that he hopes will buy alex
and bobby enough time to save naomi
on the other side of this impending
showdown is kamina drummer with her
three belter ships
and two of the free navy's martian
gunships throughout season five drummer
has been pushed to the edge in service
of our newfound polyamorous family
they made the collected decision that
joining the free navy was the best way
to ensure their survival
and this requires drummer putting her
feelings aside
overlooking the deaths of ashford and
fred johnson
and the current situation with naomi
this all eventually boils over with
drummer neutralizing coral who was put
on her ship by marco to make sure she
followed orders
in a dramatic series of events she's
able to even the scales
giving the rossi a chance to defeat the
martian ships
in the process of that she alienates
half of her family
as they know this will come with the
price of losing their husband
serge who's on marco's ship after they
watch him get spaced drummer tries to
keep the family together
arguing this was the only way they could
choose their own path
and that there was nowhere safe that
they could go but at least they could
stay together
oksana and bertol leave and this is
difficult for drummer but it had seemed
clear for the past few
episodes that there was no way she was
going to be able to
continue to operate under the free
navy's banner alex and bobby do make it
to the chatsmoka which is essentially a
bomb waiting to be triggered by
proximity sensors
they're walking right into marco's trap
naomi ended up as bait here after she
tried to reach out to her son
who had been hidden away from her when
he was a baby by her ex
mr free navy himself marco inaros when
she went to see
philip he kidnapped her and put her in
the middle of their plot she was able to
survive a hard vacuum
transit to get away but hasn't been able
to take control of the ship or its calm
system
as the razorback gets close she decides
her only option is to sacrifice herself
to warn them
and she throws herself out into the void
with only minutes worth of air inside
the suit
in the excerpt from the book that i
opened the video with she makes it clear
that she was willing to die
if that's what it would take to protect
her crew in what will be remembered as
one of the most cinematically beautiful
sequences the expanse has ever put
together
we watch her floating alone flashing her
warning signals
as we focus on her face watching as
she's breathing in her final breath
bobby arrives to insert a bottle of air
and recharge her suit
saving her and bringing her ordeal to an
end
unfortunately this victory comes with
the cost after learning that holden was
throwing himself into an unwinnable
situation to buy them time
alex resolved to get close to the
chatsumoka no matter what
he engaged in a high g maneuver approach
that bobby tried to talk him out of
because it was so dangerous
and in the end he suffered a stroke as a
result he died flying
and he died trying to save his crew and
we know those were the things that
mattered most to him
most of amos's story finished up in the
ninth episode when he made his escape
from earth
in the finale he does put his past
behind him when he says goodbye to eric
and he's there to support his crew which
now only has three members
when they're reunited he's there to tell
naomi that alex chose to sacrifice
himself in order to save a member of his
family
and that's as good of a last stand as a
person could ask for
this works on so many levels because we
know naomi was willing to sacrifice
herself we know holden was willing to do
the same
but we can also imagine that in her own
mind it'll be very hard for naomi to
forgive herself
so hearing this from amos who's also
someone she knows without a doubt would
sacrifice himself to protect their
family
really goes a long way avasarala has
become the secretary general
we see that she's making moves to undo
the aggression her predecessor
showed when he attacked palace station
she brings everyone together
we find out that bobby is now working as
her liaison and that the rossi will be
joining the fight against the free navy
as an independent ship they won't fly
anyone's flag
but this isn't a fight they can stay out
of
their get-together is interrupted when
they learn about an attack at the
ringgate it turns out that throwing
rocks at earth
and stealing the proto-molecule is only
phase one of the free navy's plan
they've actually joined forces with high
ranking officers in the martian navy
that have put together a breakaway fleet
marco exchanged the proto-molecule
sample and the diversion from his attack
to get his navy
and as the battle of soul gate rages we
learn that the breakaway fleet are
trying to transit
we also learn that medina station which
controls the choke point inside the ring
space
is under free navy control when we see
torpedoes come through the ring to
damage the inner planet's ships
this turns the tide and soul gate is
lost this is a huge victory
because now the free navy controls all
of the rings
in the unn war room avasarala asked
holden why the martians would want to
take protomolecule through the rings
after what happened on illus this brings
up the conversation emily babbage had
with alex way back in episode three and
we get further confirmation that they're
planning to use the proto-molecule to
advance their cause
when we see the conversation with
cortazar on laconia
so who is this breakaway fleet we met
soviter
early in the season because bobby
suspected he was involved with her
investigation of black market weapons
sales
she believed that there was someone
above him and on the bar keith we
learned his name was admiral duarte
at this point he's a mystery on the show
and the only previous mention of his
name
was in the finale of season 4 when it
showed up on bobby's hand terminal
when she was trying to find out who was
behind asa's last job
in the book's version of events alex met
duarte himself when he was helping bobby
but the show
probably for casting reasons changed
that to him meeting soviter
the scene of the bar keith approaching
laconia ring is a very close adaptation
of the fifth book's epilogue
the things we learn here are most of
what there is to know about their plan
until later books this is a group of
people who think the problem with mars
is that they just aren't martian enough
they see the current leadership on mars
as too soft with the ring gates opening
they saw an opportunity to see some of
that military might for themselves
get a hold of the proto-molecule sample
and create a situation where they could
transit through
a ring to create a new system of their
own
they want to turn on the artifacts the
gate builders left behind on the planet
and we know how that's turned out in the
past
we get a hint of their vision as soviets
talking
he says you understand that what we're
doing changes things
and hints that laconia will be organized
as a military
dictatorship babbage says we have to be
more pure
now than mars ever was one mind one
cause
this all ties together with what i was
talking about in the opening of the
video
they believe the ring gates opening
marked a shift in power
essentially they believe that they're
the right people with the right mindset
and they need to carve out their place
in this new order of course sobiter and
babbage won't be around to see that
realize
because as the bar keith begins to
transit the ring
things take a turn they actually start
to break down in the books it's
described as turning into clouds
while this is happening something more
sinister seems to be going on
and it looks like something's moving
through everything slashing things
breaking them up into their component
atoms
visually it looks similar to what elvie
saw when she passed through the bullet
artifact on illus
and the simulation she created to send
holden and fred johnson
certainly looks connected this is from
sovitera's chapter in the book he turned
and saw something move
something else not another cloud like
himself like the others like mater
something solid but obscured by the
emptiness of material like a shape in
the fog
many shapes neither light nor dark but
some other thing
some third side of that coin passing
through the spaces between the spaces
rushing towards them toward him after
elvie's experience with the investigator
she told holden i could feel the spaces
between
things something was there a presence
moving towards me
and holden says he feels the same thing
every time he passes through a ring
if we put all that together it's not a
stretch to say that what killed the ring
builder civilization is behind what
happened to the barquet
the book clears up some things that you
might not have picked up from the show
what happens is the ship essentially
disappears it goes
into the ring but never comes out the
other side in the story of book five the
bar keith is not the only ship that
disappeared in transit but it is the
first where we witnessed what happens to
the people inside the phenomenon
is known as going dutchman and no one
knows why it happens at this point the
laconia ring is still there and should
still be operational
other ships from the breakaway fleet
made it through the ring before the bar
keith approached it
and ships have continued to transit
rings after ships went dutchman in the
past
that's really all we know about laconia
at this point
we've seen that they have cortisol they
have the protomolecule
on the planet and that there's orbital
platforms above it
in the closing credits scene we see that
there's something there
and it's been activated by the
proto-molecule or at least that looks
like that when you see the blue coloring
moving around
so to wrap everything up the rossi crew
is back together but they paid the price
losing a member of their family alex was
more than just a pilot but his absence
also means that they have to find a new
one as for that
and just generally what i think about
his death and how that changes the story
i'll get into that more when i do my
season six questions video in a couple
of days
holden let clarissa seek refuge on the
ship and that emphasizes the bond he has
with
amos and the inherent trust that goes
along with that
marco had a big victory taking soul gate
and when you combine that with him
throwing the rocks at earth and mars
losing their military strength
it really sets the table for war there's
really no scenario you can imagine where
things just stay the way they are
through his interactions with naomi
philip and even drummer to an extent
it's pretty obvious that marco only
cares about power while he speaks to
real issues that the belters face
his actions aren't guided by that his
deal with the future laconians made it
possible for him to stir things up and
grab a bit of power
so we'll have to see what he does with
it avasarala seems to have the right
ideas on how to unite people against the
free navy but the moderate faction of
the opa has a fred johnson sized hole in
it the laconians are an interesting
twist
and once again the humans are messing
with the proto-molecule
because what he's seen inside the ring
station with the investigator what he
saw on ellis
holden is still one of the only people
who really understand how dangerous this
is
and with everything else that's going on
he may be the only one who's really
paying attention
and that seems like a great place to
leave it let me know what you think in
the comments and if you have any
questions about what happened in season
5
and questions you have about the
upcoming season 6.
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
i'll have more expanse videos coming out
this week thanks for watching i'll talk
to you soon